We have devoted much time to ours
old girlfriend glucose, which is monosaccharide.
It is the building block of glycogen,
of starch and of chitin.
But in this video I want to pay a little attention
another highly expressed monosaccharide,
this is fructose.
Fructose is often called fruit sugar.
It is monosaccharide and
is the sweetest of all sugars.
Now we will compare glucose and fructose.
The first thing that can impress you -
you can compare the two molecules -
It would be useful to be able to paint your own
these two molecules,
because you will see them many, many, many times
while studying biology, chemistry
and organic chemistry.
If we compare them, we will see that both molecules
have six carbon atoms. So for both
in the chemical formula we will have
six carbon atoms. Then we see that both have
one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12.
They have 12 hydrogen atoms and to finish,
have six oxygen atoms.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Both molecules have six oxygen atoms.
So they have the same chemical formula,
but they are different molecules, making them isomers.
As we shall see, they are structural isomers.
The compilers
carbon, hydrogen and oxygen atoms
are connected in a different way.
So we call them structural isomers.
And if you look,
there is one main thing that will make you impression.
The glucose molecule when in
its open form,
we will think of her,
we will think of both molecules in their cyclical form in a second.
But when it is in its open form,
the glucose molecule has a carbonyl group
the carbon atom number number one, if we start the numbering here.
If we start numbering - one, two, three, four,
five, six, the open-chain glucose has a carbonyl group
on its first carbon atom. While fructose,
has a carbonyl group.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
of its second carbon atom.
Remember, the carbonyl group is simply a carbon atom linked to a double bond
with oxygen. Fructose has a C?
its second carbon atom.
This is the main structural difference.
Even if you look at the way I drew them,
we have three hydroxyl groups
on the right and
one on the left. Three on the right,
one on the left.
So the main difference is what we explained here.
Now we will get some more experience
with the names of the different function groups.
When we were learning about glucose, we knew there was
carbonyl group at the end of the carbon chain.
The carbon atom in the carbonyl group is bound
with a hydrogen atom and with the rest of the carbon chain.
We call it here
aldehyde functional group.
Aldehyde, an aldehyde function group that makes
whole molecule
aldehyde.
Where the carbon in the carbonyl group is not
at the end of the chain, and in the middle
or rather it is in the chain,
not exactly in the middle,
this carbon atom is linked to two other carbon atoms.
We call this molecule a ketone.
This will be a keto group,
because the carbon atom is connected
with two other carbon atoms.
Therefore, fructose
is considered a ketone.
Now to think how he can form
its cyclical form. As we have said before,
the open and cyclic form can
be in equilibrium if they are in aqueous solution.
What I paint here is not the only one
forms that glucose takes. If you look
in textbooks or on the internet,
you will see the most common
in nature form, when we talk about cyclic forms,
you will find glucose as a six-membered ring,
right here.
Five of the ring atoms are carbon, and the last one
is oxygen.
While fructose most often forms a five-atom ring,
in which four of the atoms are carbon
and one is oxygen.
Glucose may form a six-membered ring,
when we have a six-membered ring,
when we have a carbohydrate that forms a six-membered
a ring in which one of the atoms is oxygen,
we call it pyranose. Pyranose is a carbohydrate ring which,
there are six members one of which is oxygen.
When there are five members,
one of which is oxygen, the name is furanose.
Furanose.
In fact, fructose can be detected as a furanose
and as pyranose. But furanose
is also most typical when people think
for the fructose ring, most often think of
this shape.
How to get it
this shape?
Especially in comparison with what happens in glucose?
We saw,
that in glucose
but also in fructose,
the carbon atom that is part of the carbonyl group will be attacked.
Here's the carbon atom number one.
This is the number one carbon atom,
and here is carbon atom number two.
It's carbon atom number two.
Carbon atom number two here,
in both cases --
If we want to get these forms
here
we have an oxygen atom that is
in the hydroxyl group
at the fifth carbon atom.
Oxygen in the hydroxyl group bound
with the fifth carbon atom.
This is the first, second, third, fourth, fifth carbon atom.
This oxygen
formed
this connection here when we talk about
glucose, and this one here,
when we talk about fructose. If we look at oxygen atom number five
in the hydroxyl group of the fifth
carbon atom, we see the hydroxyl group here.
This is this hydroxyl group
and this oxygen atom.
This oxygen atom
forms a connection
with the carbon atom in the carbonyl group.
When this happens, it allows
of one of these double bonds
to free itself from the carbon atom and
to form a connection
with a proton floating around.
This proton would probably be
of the hydroxone ion.
The same thing would happen to glucose
here.
One of these double links will be used,
to connect
with a hydrogen proton,
so in practice it's the same mechanism.
The reason is a five-membered ring with four
carbon atom rather than a six-membered ring of five,
is that the carbonyl group
is down the chain
in glucose. That's why she's forming
this pentagonal shape here.
We have already talked about it in other videos.
Fructose, as I said,
is the sweetest sugar of all monosaccharides.
When we talk about table sugar,
which you may add in your tea or coffee,
table sugar is called sucrose.
Sucrose, sucrose.
It is a disaccharide made up of glucose and fructose.
The way in which the relationship takes place is also
by dehydration,
in which
oxygen
at the first carbon atom in glucose,
this one here,
I will color it in a color I have not used so far.
But I have used almost all colors, so it will be difficult.
I'm just going to use this green.
This oxygen can form a bond
p
carbon atom number two of fructose.
When the bond is formed,
this connection here,
I will color it in another color,
can return to oxygen
or if you want to look at it in another way,
can be used to form a link
with a hydrogen proton,
which floats through the solution.
Carbon will bind to oxygen,
who will connect with another
carbon atom.
Another water molecule
can attract this hydrogen proton here
and then we will have
connection,
with which we are already familiar.
These glycosidic linkages are obtained
in dehydration, these connections
are the basis of how we start with mono-saccharides
and create
disaccharides. If we continue,
we will create polysaccharides.
One way to think about sucrose is,
if we have
glucose here,
glucose,
I will draw it here
we have glucose,
we have glucose.
Glucose forms
glycosidic bond
with fructose,
with fructose
right here.
And sucrose is produced.
To really imagine it,
we will rotate the fructose and lift it up,
then they can connect.
This atom will form a bond with this carbon atom
right here.